let's see who we want to talk to next
how about a read from milwaukee
read from milwaukee you're on the air
hey david how are you i'm doing well
um so i've actually got some
constructive criticism for you
beautiful um so this
has to go back to uh something that you
said about
i forget it was a fox interview about
china uh
biden about how they were how biden
wouldn't respond to
um yeah let me let me explain it so the
the the clip was
correct me if i'm wrong um that someone
someone uh alleged that if
china nuked us biden would do nothing
yeah yeah um i
i i think the way that you said that
like you you said
if china nuked us you know when they
talk about nuclear aggression
um generally that means like
you know just showing steps of you know
nuclear tests
stuff like that at least that's my
opinion
um i and i think sometimes you you get a
little hyperbolic with stuff
okay uh specifically in that case um
yeah anyway so just thought i would uh
share that all right
was that it yeah oh okay all right thank
you very much
yeah no i think um i mean listen i i
responded to it as i saw it i saw it as
it was being
alleged that joe biden is so weak on
china he would let them nuke us and
wouldn't even do anything and obviously
i thought that that was a ridiculous
assertion to make but i'll review the
video again
thank you all right very good thank you
for the call that's going to do it for
today
i'm sorry i wasn't able to talk to
everybody but we did talk to lots of
interesting people
we'll take a quick break and we will
take calls again in the future